one of the big examinations you can do
is the fact that you and everybody dies
one day
how much you author Isaacson think about
death are you afraid of it no and I
don't think about it a lot but I do
think about Steve Jobs is let me tell
you a story you know which is the
wonderful Steve Jobs story of um I think
after he was diagnosed but before it was
public and he gave both a Stanford talk
but other things
in which he said
the fact that we are going to die
gives you focus and gives you meaning if
you're gonna live and Elon Musk has said
that to me which is a lot of the tech
Bros out in the Silicon Valley that are
looking for ways to live forever forever
I can think much as of nothing worse we
read the myth of Sisyphus and we know
how bad it is to be condemned to
eternal life
so
there was an ancient Greece the person
who walked behind the king and said
momento Mori remember you're gonna die
and it kept
people
from
losing it a bit